well las vegas magician xavier mortimer
has officially opened his new show at
the strat theater jillian joins us live
and we hear xavier might have a trick up
his sleeve for us today hey jillian
hey you guys guess we are making the
magic happen here at the strat theater i
am joined by xavier mortimer to talk
about his new show the dream maker tell
us a little bit before we get to the
trick of what people can expect when
they come to your show here at the
stride well it's uh it's a magic show
but it's a different show it's a show
with a story line there's illusions
illusions that you've never seen before
it's not like the classic box and card
thing it's um it's
i'm flying on boxes i'm flying with the
jump rope i'm playing with my shadows
playing with the lights there's a lot of
like very whimsical and dream like like
the title of the show dream like magic
there's a story line so i'm pursuing
my quest of my dream girl i make her
appear she disappears she reappears
and
there's a lot of comedy juggling a lot
of things in the show oh so you're
you're romantic and we get to see that
on the stage play out i love it and i
hear that you have a little trick
planned for me today yeah there's one
trick that i have in the show but i need
uh i need some tape do you have some
gaff tape or something oh there we go
our photographer lance saving the day
all right let's see it
so i'm going to show you something it's
a
quick thing i do in the show it's how to
dress up in a second you put like this
and it looks like a tie sure
hold on
i can do better okay let's see
okay there we go it looks like a tie
three times one two three
oh it looks like a tie so is this real
can we touch it to prove it look at this
oh my gosh this is so fun and this is
just one of the many tricks that you do
and you have quite the following on
youtube so we've seen a lot of your
tricks on there will you do some of
those on stage here at the strat too yes
we have been publishing a lot of content
on youtube facebook instagram everywhere
online you can follow it at xavier
mortimer and some of this content
because we couldn't perform in the
theater we have been creating a lot of
themes and some of this content is right
now in the show oh that is so fun if you
want to come check out xavier be sure to
come to the strat he performs nightly at
6 p.m and can you tell me how you did
this or is that a secret it's magic it's
magic there you go you heard it here
i'll send it back to you guys thanks
jillian i'm so confused
it was really cool i want to try it with
you now kendall
xavier mortimer the dream maker nightly
uh performance is at 6 00 p.m dark on
tuesdays and it's all happening at the
strat theater you can get your tickets
at the strat.com